hey guys today's deals birthday your
birthday present was such a sweet gift
from Bart which was like a memorial
blanket of Tyson I thought it was
adorable and back here is Bonnie and
drynke and we are all packed up and
ready to go to the bee whoa and who is
next to you good bunny
Oh David yeah there's Barton oh and
here's a birthday girl
I know it's amazing uh your phone cover
haha so I'm all ready to go we're gonna
go meet Joe and the rest of the doggies
at the beach
oh gee we
are you
they can
with my uncle's ever Cobo poeple like
this always good I beg recite over here
look at all the doggies everybody so
happy we found her spa all right so now
we're all set up at the beach and we're
chillin here with Bonnie girl and Gio
just took boonie bear to go see the
water for the first time it's a
beautiful day here in Southern
California
I'm deal birthday but to connect I'm
just chillin taking care of the campsite
I guess you could call it
tiny tiny baby girl
Isaac is on Bart's shoulders ha he was
just screaming right now with a booty go
o booties over there chillin with that
good oh look who's here
hey hey wow you're slobbering like crazy
boy
Oh
accomplished okay now we're all vlogging
everyone's logging their dog and logging
Isaac we are
oh my God he's like forget that
let's go you gotta taste the water let
me up when you girl come here pretty
girl
she's like I'm not having it
this is the butt smelling fest
coming here funny she's like yeah
yeah yeah
you go in the water
good girl mom I see not that bad
yeah a fun baby were you waiting for
people let me throw her you're both fine
forget you Oh Isaac is was for I don't
know he's gonna do
Oh cute the student singing that stuff
Lysol water make some food yeah your son
swimming it no idea oh my god bro
get the kids I think it's getting cool
you want the talent oh you want to get
out you look like you're freezing
this kid dope practice in his kickin
I think why are you scared
hahaha you got you got you got you
Oh cute that's like volts mini week
looks like Joe is thinking can be
something
what see what is this
you're helping the water very joe of you
to do
working away oh nice
I beg now your Sam kid
oh my gosh really too bad Katie couldn't
come but he would have totally died here
because he's allergic to dogs and then
Brianna was like yeah that's if I would
go to a Cathy stint I just have a visual
Kathy Sheran
so freakin hilarious yeah I'm allergic
to cat I would like them though but
imagine a cat reads they're like no cat
to be in the water they hate the water
so now we are packing up we gotta go get
ready because we are gonna go to Gio's
birthday dinner
not
so we just got home from the beach as
soon as we got home
Isaac dad was waiting for him at the
front of the house so Isaac is already
off to his daddy's house to spend the
weekend but I got boonie here with me
still cuz David is actually moving in
that whole moving process he was like
I'm not gonna be able to make it to
jails dinners I'm still busy but you
know if you can still keep booty for me
for a second while I finish up moving so
we're gonna be dropping off boonie in
k-town at his old place right before we
go to dinner but now that I have boonie
hair I want her to meet Joe and Maya and
I want to see how their reactions will
be so let's see what happened
you excited boonie you're gonna meet
though in my ass yeah maybe we kept
there waiting I love it I was a doggish
it was so much fun I missed you very
much come here so I want you to meet
wanting to meet David baby
balloony here we go pony Zoe
really she's like yeah so not under like
no no so is it nice guy talking to my
critters she's scared she's more scared
of zonin those nosy those ready he's
like what the [ __ ] are you that's just
John oh my gosh she's not crazy
okay okay be like you know relax look at
look at this girl oh yeah again are you
gonna get it out you know you're
allergic but okay
well that was anticlimactic okay I gotta
get ready for deals dinner
yes group girl group Brazilian barbecue
YUM
here at NREL hello guys hey I just saw
you not too long ago
hello hello hello hello hello hello five
anymore
we're still surprised they were still
surprising all right
happy birthday
Oh
yeah
yeah